Speaker 1: Following up on all the holiday
weekend news failed. Former President Donald
Trump did an interview so humiliating that even
his friend Wayne Allyn Root couldn't save him.
When Alan Root has been a guest on this program
many times. I encourage you to check out my
conversations with Wayne and you will probably
learn a lot about the type of person that he
is politically. He was interviewed sorry, he
interviewed Donald Trump over the weekend. And
we're going to just look at some of it. And it's
all pretty nauseating, to be perfectly frank.
Speaker 3: Huge fan and President Trump, big
fan. Sir, I welcome you to America's Top ten
Countdown with way down. How are you?
Speaker 2: Good, thanks. Wayne,
it's great being with you. It's always great being
with you is we've done some good work together.
Speaker 3: We have, you know you
know, I'm on your team, by the way.
Speaker 1: The explosive platform
Rumble was able to deliver
27,000 views for this interview, which is, oh.
Speaker 3: Boy, under 10% forever. I know that.
For life. Yeah. And that's my ballgame. When
I'm loyal. I'm loyal, and that's it. I never go
back. We need you as president and my opening
commentary, which you haven't even heard yet,
but I'm sure you'll get a chance to see a
copy of the show. My opening commentary.
Speaker 1: We're going to send him
a copy of it, not the original.
They're going to send him a copy.
Speaker 3: Was for this Christmas. I
want everyone to appreciate the great gift of
President Donald J. Trump, because he is our
Braveheart. He is our William Wallace. And you
remember Mel Gibson's movie Braveheart. It's you
fighting against the Deep State. Well, of.
Speaker 1: Course, I remember that movie
when and by the way, Mel Gibson was treated
totally unfairly by that Jewish cop. Completely
unfairly. Gibson was right to ask, are you a
Jew? And listen, we gave you a beer. We sorry,
what c swamp.
Speaker 3: And you're the only
thing between them and all of us being serfs and
slaves. So we appreciate you. I appreciate you.
And I pray to God you're back again in 24.
Speaker 2: Well, that's really nice. And
the rhinos, too, you know, the rhinos are
really bad in a lot of ways. They're worse
than the Democrats right here. You know
where the Democrats are coming from. But
these rhinos that we have and guys like Mitch
McConnell is so bad like this omnibus bill,
it's not even it's not even believable.
They're going to pass it. Horrible. It's
just an incredible thing. And see how
he gets away with this stuff. Go ahead.
Speaker 3: I know you.
Speaker 1: By the way, the
talking over each other is the entire interview.
Speaker 3: On the omnibus bill. I saw your
comments today. It is terrible.
How can the Republicans vote for
this? Why would Republicans vote for this?
Speaker 2: Because Mitch McConnell raises money
and he gives it to Republican senators and they
go out and vote. Very simple. He's not a leader.
He just raises money and he gives it you know, he
pays, gives him a lot of money. And it's amazing,
you know, that they can get that by
because they needed ten senators,
ten or 12, and he gets the ten or 12, including
himself, the horrible bill, do you know, and the
border security. We had nothing. And yet we're
giving four or five countries border security
for almost $500 million. So they're allowed to
have border security. And we're not it's not
even it's not even passable what they are doing.
Speaker 1: Now, remember, nobody on the left is
saying we can't have a border or border security.
There's just there's no one on the left is saying
that. The point is, can we fix immigration, deal
with DOCA, actually determine what we think we're
solving with a wall, realize it won't actually
work and put in place solutions that make sense.
These are straw man arguments on immigration.
Speaker 2: If they waited for two or three weeks,
you'd you'd have the Republican Congress
helping and would make a much better deal.
But he does when you want to get it done
before the Republican Congress comes in.
Speaker 3: This is America's top ten countdown
show. So I come up with the top ten. Right. And
you just covered quite a few of them. In other
words, I said, here's a bill. How convenient.
Border security, the Middle East countries, but
none to ours. And he has a bill that gives another
45 billion to Ukraine. But their invasion. But
what about our border invasion? If Title 42 gets
lifted, what's going to happen to America?
Speaker 1: Now let's talk about Title 42.
Title 42 was used by Trump to more quickly send
migrants back to their home countries. Okay.
Now the justification was we have a unique
and explosive public health emergency COVID.
Trump was simultaneously downplaying the severity
of the pandemic while saying It is so historically
bad that we need to use Title 42 to turn
migrants around and do expedited deportations.
Or how? Wait. It's both. Not super serious, but
so serious. We need to use something in a way
that it hasn't been used for a really, really
long time because it is such an emergency. It
was pure politics. That's all it was.
Speaker 2: Well, right now it's doing
better than we thought. And the courts the
courts are sort of holding it up because,
you know, the judges are saying like, this
is crazy what they're doing to our country,
you know? It gets beyond the legal. It gets like
it's common sense, most of this stuff. And it'll
certainly be a horrible thing. And right
now it's extended to past the weekend. But,
you know, I was the one that put it in. It was my.
Speaker 1: Idea. All right. So Trump both taking
credit for criticizing, so immigration's a
complete and total mess. Let's skip ahead
to another section just to give you a
little bit of the other flavor here.
Speaker 3: Yeah, no, I get it. Listen, I
think you're as loyal as anyone to the Jewish
people in the history of the White House.
Speaker 1: Oh, right into it. Nobody's been
better for the Jews than you, Don. Nobody.
Speaker 3: And I understand your anger. I
understand your questioning. Why the heck you're
not getting the Jewish vote being a loyal base?
I get it. I'm Jewish and I get it. So I guess.
Speaker 1: We've explained it before. Republicans
and their pro-Israel view, the way they define
it mostly appeals to evangelical Christians,
not to Jewish Americans who overwhelmingly vote
for Democrats because on issues, Jewish-Americans
overwhelmingly line up with Democrats.
How many times do we have to explain this?
Speaker 2: 25% of the Jewish vote. In 2016,
I got 25% of the Jewish vote. And I didn't
do it for votes. I did it because it was the
right thing to do. Then I did Golan Heights,
which is a big deal. They're trying to get it for
60 years. I got it done in 15 minutes. I did Golan
Heights, which is unbelievably important. But more
importantly, I did the embassy. I did Jerusalem.
Speaker 1: Remember the embassy? What it
means is moving the U.S. embassy from Tel
Aviv to Jerusalem. That only appeals to right
wing Americans. That's who that appeals to.
Progressive Jews like me recognize that you
can't just unilaterally say, we're putting the
embassy in Jerusalem because it goes right at the
heart of much of the Israeli-Palestinian conflict
and the sovereignty of Jerusalem, and whether
Jerusalem in an eventual two state solution,
which may never come, whether Jerusalem will
or won't be the international capital of Israel
over a hypothetical Palestinian state. There's
a reason why moving the embassy to Jerusalem
didn't make progressive Jews, which is most of us
come scrambling to vote for Trump, but he either
doesn't get it or he doesn't want to accept it.
Speaker 2: Becoming the capital. I do know.
Speaker 1: The gap and.
Speaker 3: I know.
Speaker 2: That I did great there. All right.
And then I did know and then I did the Iran
nuclear deal and terminated it, which is
it was probably the most valuable thing I
did if you're one, because they want to
they want to terminate Israel. So I did
the Iran nuclear deal. And then a guy calls
me up who I know who's been very good, the.
Speaker 1: Big, strong guy. He was crying over it.
Speaker 2: It was on Tucker Carlson the other day,
couple of months ago saying Trump is great and he
wanted to have dinner because I think he needed
help. Because he needs help. But I think he needed
help. Yeah. Yeah. And all of a sudden they say,
oh, I'm having dinner with him and he's an
anti-Semite. Now, how am I supposed to know?
He's an anti he is an anti-Semite. He didn't
express that to me, by the way, whatever he is.
Speaker 1: How was I supposed to be
aware of the major global story about
Kanye that lasted two weeks on every news outlet?
Speaker 2: So all of a sudden, no, no. Now we've
got to have more loyalty.
Speaker 1: The Jews should
be more loyal to me, Wayne. Like you?
Speaker 3: Yeah. No, I get it. Listen, Obama
sat in the pew of an antique store for 20 years.
You know, secretaries at his church, Reverend
Wright. And nobody ever said a word about it. The
media, liberals, no one. You have one dinner with
a stranger, and the whole world is against you.
Speaker 1: All right, so anyway, I won't do
this. The entire thing is 19 minutes
long. I think we've had enough of it.
But a friendly interview and Trump ends
up with the Jews should be more loyal to
me. The Jews should be more loyal to me for
that thing I did where I move the carpet,
the embassy, unbelievable stuff even
way now. And route can't save Trump.